Hi, this is your travel host, Naomi.
I'd like to show you the top five attractions of Helsinki, Finland.
Number five: The unusual and amazing church carved in a rock.
You'll find a calm, peaceful setting inside.
Number four: National Museum of Finland, located in a gorgeous building,...
...the museum showcases Finland's history from prehistoric to present times.
Number three: Uspenski Cathedral, built in 1868,...
...it is Western Europe's largest Orthodox church.
Russia's influence is evident in its red facade.
Number two: Suomenlinna Island, a short ferry ride from Helsinki,...
...it has an imposing 19th century fortress.
The site is on the UNESCO world heritage list.
And number one: Helsinki Cathedral, one of the most iconic landmarks of Helsinki.
A neoclassical styled 19th century church, it's a must-see for all visitors.
Thank you for watching our travel video series.
See you next time.